we're in for a believer yeah and I
really love further motive because of
just how grounded in reality is we have
to make decisions on the basis of
probability all the time but usually we
kind of do it intuitively like even when
you've got numbers like you look at the
web rap and you're like oh 90 degrees
today and there's a 47% chance of rain
we still kind of I think resort to
really intuitively do I need to bring an
umbrella or do I just love all right I
mean great yeah I think about these
things mathematically is you can go
beyond what your just long intuition can
handle because the numbers are far more
accurate now in the situations that
we've been having look at an answering
question you guys have already had a
look at a few different visual tools
that you can use does the understand
particular scenario would anyone like to
help your member just go back to
yesterday afternoon
once example with one visual tool that
we know we can use in probability they
also understand a situation a tree
diagram because it's open these in no
particular for a tree diagram David can
someone give me another one
yeah burrows and array thank you very
much wish in the past 1/4 take dot
diagram that's same deal now these two
are probably the main when you spend
some time on I'm gonna give you another
two one of them which doesn't even feel
like a different woman
I'll justify it in the second if you
have a lot of different sort of parts of
your event use a tree or a grant that
sometimes the situation is sufficiently
simple that if you just take all the
options in the sample spaces just put
them a list just make sure you've got
all of them there you have a
comprehensive list so you can say here
the ones that are good the favourable
here are the ones they're not that's
fine okay now here's the important thing
an arrangement with its have development
on page you need to know when it is that
you use each one of these tools right
the whole idea is we're giving you Mike
a tool box and there's a hammer and a
screwdriver and a wrench in there and we
want you to be able to use all of those
tools but just as important is knowing
when are you supposed to use a hand
instead of screwdriver you would know
when she's well yellow so that's
everything about this right I'm actually
gonna start at the wanna be young and I
kind of clued you into this in what
situations would you just list out some
of the outcomes in the situation you
probably don't want to do it when
there's a lot of different things right
so in other words when do you use of
this where there's a very small sample
space if you have a look at your
scenario and you're like wow there's
only four different things that can
happen here right well don't use some
big fancy tool for it just say 1 2 3 4 5
it's all there ok alright that was me
sort of
pull your hand let's have a think about
an array under what circumstances could
you cover weight under what
circumstances would you use it arrest
her beautiful eyes your situation you
may like something back in your book or
when you did use em already
if you use that are a few times have
think about what's in common between
each of those situations be back it's
very good
yeah
if you have to knows I'm going to say to
nice is like the classic situation
happens so often I'm glad that's where
you live estimate that's the example did
you I give me another Nugent or I'll say
monk yes yeah very good sir don't worry
about during this but that's pretty much
bang on if you think about what an array
looks like for example with the two nuts
we go one two three four five six
what's your view four five six right uh
you could for example if it was any two
events you could say they'd be rolling a
die and then flipping a coin yeah
he was so good at one two three four
five six and then you would just say
head tail but the key is if there's two
situations you can represent one
horizontally one vertically I should say
two events right if there was just one
event is showing a single die this is a
bit pointless like why would you need
both things and by the same circuit if
you would say flipping three coins
flipping three coins you copy the uses
tool can you cuz you get a first point
second coin oh your ear bit stuck right
so therefore and that leads us to the
next thing right when do you use an
array it's really when you've got two
parts to the event to plants through the
event so maybe I'll lead you to thinking
about the at the moment anyway the most
complicated tool that we have for
visualize these situations is a tree
maybe you can kind of see if you can
follow the path I know what
circumstances would use a trait say one
part of women is one part of it now
cigarettes with me let's give an example
or one time it might be sad Rahl is
single why would we use a tree for this
or one of the other tools be more
helpful perhaps what would you do if it
was a garbage yeah I think sensing one
two three four five six this it's simple
but it gets every
yeah I'd actually probably want not a
less complicated event but probably a
more complicated event would be more
appropriate for a tree does that make
sense yes I guess a way we can say that
is when there's like a multi part of
anymore especially when there's more
than two now there's one other thing if
you've got another color that it might
be hopeful here you remember when I
mention all doing - that's right one two
three one two six one two six one of the
key things that we tend to use a race
for is when every single one of the
options every single one of the possible
combinations when they all have equal
chance if every single option your array
is equally likely now we go to the
distinguish really is it more likely
aroma double six or double one and the
answer is will be the same right every
single event has an equal chance what is
it about a tree diagram that makes it a
bit more useful when you don't have yeah
when you can um write the chance and
like the line that connects them and
then you multiply them if you've got a
tree here right as is just mentioned we
could put like you know different
numbers different fractions on these
branches as you've seen before and what
this indicates is one thing is more
likely there's another so not only I
mean sometimes even when you've only got
two parts to your event you use a tree
anyway like this because you have very
chances all of your difference as a G or
your difference right so this is just
sort of making sure that you've got an
either one you need to use all these
tools but when to use them is just
important okay now if he comes there
heading that way we're going to talk
today about the fourth visual tool which
is something you've actually used before
it's a Venn diagram right and some of
the verbally describe me what does it
mean diagram look like only two circles
yeah generally the most commonly you see
is two overlapping circles as you're
going to see in a second sometimes it
will be exactly that but that's the
basic idea
okay that's in the I have you by the way
Venn diagrams now hopefully it is pink
baby home in the table is begging the
question okay well you've got a simple
simple Evangelist well you've got a 2 pi
then everything is equally likely use a
break when you've got perhaps many many
parts three or four or when the parts
all have different chances that's always
a tree you know to write this but I want
you by the end of this lesson to be able
to answer for me in what circumstances
is a Venn diagram the way to go I'm not
going to tell you I'm just really going
to walk you through enough that we can
do it okay